I had spent a very enjoyable weekend
reading your Pluto comments. Uh,
no, that was fun. Uh, it
is a surprisingly, uh,
it's a surprisingly deep topic.
There's technical issues about
how orbits of planets work. Uh,
there are these interesting
cultural and political
currents that underlie the
whole thing. Uh, and uh,
uh,
also some sort of deep
philosophy or what the literary,
uh, professors like to call
theory about what it means,
what it means to name something and what
the consequences of particular names
are. Uh, and, uh,
so I thought I would make a couple of
comments on the Pluto thing first before
we get, uh, get back to the
hot Jupiters. Let's see. Uh,
the first thing I would say,
let me encourage you all when
you get this kind of a question,
answer the question that's asked
the biggest problem in, uh,
the answers that I saw where
that sometimes you just
didn't address the specific
question that was asked.
What I asked was to what extent is
the Pluto controversy a scientific
controversy?
You don't answer that by a narrative
describing what happens if you say,
well they discovered Eris and then
that through the scientific world into
confusion and they had this big meeting
and there was all this fuss. Uh,
and then people started to get involved,
weren't scientists and so forth.
That doesn't answer the question because
the question was to what extent is this
a scientific controversy?
There are two possible categories
of answer to that question. One is,
yes,
it was a,
it is primarily a scientific controversy
and the other category is no,
it was primarily not a
scientific controversy.
And if you didn't say one of those
things or something somewhere in between,
then that's not kind of
responsive to the question.
I would say that you could answer that
particular question in this case in both
directions.
Uh,
perfectly well if you want to make a
case that it's a scientific issue, uh,
you say, look, classification
is very important to science.
I made that point in class
on, uh, uh, uh, a week ago.
Uh, and that, you know,
you've got to have your classifications
right and in order to understand what's
going on and what has happened
here is new data has come in,
which has thrown the old
classifications into question,
although it should be noted that there
wasn't officially a definition of planet,
uh,
that goes back to antiquity.
And one of the things they were trying
to do was to, was to create one. Uh,
but that as new data came in from
the outer parts of the solar system,
we had to revise our classifications
in this is a key point of science.
And therefore the whole thing is,
is at root a scientific issue.
But you could also argue the
opposite in that, you know,
the scientific issue
was not really in doubt.
Nobody was questioning whether Pluto and
Eris and all those things ought to be
in the same category as Jupiter. Clearly
they're not. That wasn't the issue.
The reason this became so controversial
is because there were a lot of people
who, uh, scientists and,
and non scientists who thought that it
would be nice if Pluto could remain a
planet and therefore they came up with
these rather convoluted definitions in
order to maintain the idea that
Pluto should remain a planet.
And then they got into trouble because
50 other things would therefore also have
to be planets.
Uh,
but it's rooted in a nonscientific desire
for Pluto to remain a planet and for
very few other things to be
admitted to this pantheon.
And that is fundamentally
not a scientific thing.
And you could argue that that's the
whole root of the entire issue. Now,
uh, one of the interesting things is that
these nonscientific things affect the
scientist to a lot of you quoted this
Guy Alan Stern, who's a planetary,
a famous planetary scientist who objected
to the way it all ended up by saying,
look,
one of the definitions that they've put
down is that you have to clear out your
orbit. And Pluto doesn't
make it in that, uh, uh,
in that context because it crosses the
orbit of Neptune, which much bigger thing.
But stern goes on to say Neptune
also crosses the orbit of Pluto.
And so obviously there's some
hidden assumption here, uh,
about, you know, the,
the thing that's much more massive
counts and the thing that's less massive
doesn't count,
but that hasn't actually been stated.
And so this is a lousy definition.
And so he objected on scientific
grounds to this definition. Uh,
and some of you noted that a stern is
the principal investigator of the new
horizons mission. Uh, but I don't think
you noticed the implications of that.
The New Horizons mission is a planetary
probe that is on its way now to Pluto.
And the reason that it was launched,
the retail Al Gore was actually very
enthusiastic about this when he was vice
president.
Um,
the reason that this was launched was
because Pluto was the only one of the
planets that voyager didn't go to until
we have these fabulous pictures of,
you know,
Saturn and Uranus and Neptune.
We have no fabulous pictures of
Pluto because nothing had gone there.
And in the late 1990s, people
thought, well, this is dumb there.
What planet out there
that hasn't been explored,
we've got to have a mission to go to this
planet. So now it's seven years later,
the mission just went past a Jupiter
actually. So it's on its way out. Uh,
and all of a sudden the thing that
it's going to has been demoted. Uh,
this is awkward. Uh, you know,
we're spending $100 million of your money
to go see the last of the planet and
now it's not a planet anymore.
And here's the guy who's
in charge of that mission.
And so of course he objects to the change
in definition that demotes his object,
which you spending 15 years of his life
on $100 million of your money to study,
uh, has now been kicked out
of the realm of the planet.
So not surprising that he would
take that particular point of view.
Mike Brown's another example. That's
the guy who discovered Eris. Uh,
and he has an lovely thing on his
website about how planet ought to be a
cultural definition.
And he kind of advocates for
thing where because it's cultural,
you gotta keep Pluto in and because
you've got to keep Pluto in,
you've got to allow
anything bigger than Pluto.
So you just have an arbitrary culturally
enforced cutoff at the mass of Pluto.
Uh,
and then,
and things that are more massive get to
count also because otherwise it would be
unfair.
Look what this does though,
it meets Eris is a planet and
none of these other things are,
which means Mike Brown is one of the four
people in the history of humanity who
has discovered a planet.
Uh,
and so that's a very convenient
definition. Uh, and so, you know,
and then he actually very graciously goes
on to say, well, I'll settle for a B.
The being the discover of the largest
dwarf planet until a bigger one gets
discovered. Uh, but you can see
he's not really happy about it.
He'd much rather that thing be decal
be decreed the 10th planet and perhaps
reasonably so.
So the scientists are also affected
by these kinds of things in ways,
uh,
that you have to think a little bit
about before as you interpret what their
take on the scientific parts of
the controversy, uh, really are.
So let me summarize all of
this. This is going to be, I,
I mentioned in the first class that,
uh,
I was going to tell fables about science
with morals attached to them and that
you could then explore these further
in your optional paper if you choose to
write letters. So that here's a fable, uh,
which is the, uh, um,
the demotion of Pluto.
And one could ascribe a
variety of morals to this. But,
but let me write down one version
that happens to appeal to me,
which is,
uh,
just the fact that I think
science can be affected,
uh,
by culture and you need to keep
your eye on that kind of thing.
When you interpret things
that scientist say,
particularly if they're
saying it to journalists, uh,
they're often much more circumstance
backed into things that actually get
published in the journals. Um, okay. Uh,
there was one kind of argument that that
rubbed me the wrong way a little bit
when some of you said it, which was, uh,
people had a little bit of
a tendency to say, you know,
all this definition and classification
stuff that's the word trivial or silly is
sometimes use that kind of unimportant
and it detracts from the science.
And I have to say,
I don't agree with that.
I think it's important for the science
to get these classifications right
because otherwise you don't know how to
describe what you're looking at and you
don't know how to interpret it. Uh, oh, I
should mention a, something about grading,
I guess. Uh, it was six points
on that problem. The way I
did it was I started out,
everybody sorta started out
with five of those six points,
and if you said things that were
incomplete or incoherent or,
or a dumb in some way,
you got points taken off,
but there was also an extra point you
could get for being especially coherent,
uh, or uh, or especially
original or interesting or
just generally waking me up.
If after I'd read 40 others of them,
uh,
I bring this up just to point out that
if you get five out of six on that
particular problem, that doesn't
mean you've done anything wrong.
It wasn't that we started with a perfect
score of six and started subtracting
things off. It just
meant, uh, that, uh, uh,
I felt that there were others in the pile
who were somehow somehow more coherent.
We'll hand these things back at the end of
the, of the class, by the way, and I'll,
and I'll make some remarks about
grading of the overall problem set, uh,
at the end.
Okay.
Another general point that showed up,
uh,
in other parts of the
problem set was it was, uh,
a kind of issue about velocities
in the center of mass.
Um,
let me,
here's the center of mass of some orbit.
And of course,
that's not a physical object.
That's just a point in space. Uh,
and the key thing to understand about the,
the center of mass is the center of mass
doesn't move. It doesn't move in space.
That's, that's a fixed point in
space. So this doesn't move a,
actually I should be more precise.
Uh, it's, motion doesn't change.
So if it's stationary and some
coordinate system, it sits there.
If it's moving at some velocity,
it continues to move at precisely
that velocity so that it's,
and then you can redefine
the coordinate system. So it,
so it doesn't move in some other
coordinates system, but it doesn't,
it doesn't go around in circles, uh,
or ellipses or anything. What does,
uh, go around? Are the
things going around it?
One of which is, uh, the
planet, which is over here,
uh, the other of which is
the star, which is over here.
And the way these two things move,
they have to stay one on each side,
uh,
in a straight line that,
whoops,
I'm going to miss in a straight line
that goes through the center of mass.
And I drew that wrong.
So let me redraw it here.
There we go. Uh, yeah.
And so it balances, right?
That's what the center of mass is.
It's the balance point. And so, uh, uh,
the star has to stay exactly
opposite to the planet. Uh,
how big are each of these things?
Well,
that depends on the
ratio of the masses in,
in an equation we wrote down
before the consequences that, uh,
as these things go around, they stay on
opposite sides of the center of mass.
So the amount of time it takes the
to go around the center of mass,
that's the orbital period has to be the
same as the amount of time it takes the
star to go around the center of Matt.
Also the orbital period.
So the orbital period
p
are required to be the same because it
has to take them the same amount of time
to go round this center of mass because,
uh,
because they have to stay on opposite
sides of it the whole time. Uh, the, uh,
p is,
so the orbital period p is the same
for the planet and for the star,
whereas the velocity
and the semi major axis,
uh,
are different.
Okay.
Because while it takes the same
amount of time to go round,
the star is going for much less distance.
So the distance is shorter and therefore
the velocity has to be less for the
star.
So we can talk about the star Versus
v planet and a star versus a planet.
And we can add these things up
to make v Total and a total. Uh,
but you don't do that with the
period. The period is the same. Um,
okay, so that's, that's an
important concept. Questions.
Let me point out that this concept of
the center center of mass gets more
complicated when there's more than
one planet. Uh, because again,
the center of mass is still a fixed point.
Even when you've got two planets.
And so, uh, uh, one of the things that,
so the star is going around the
center of mass because of this planet,
but it's taking other extra
little wiggles. Uh, as a result,
if there's a second planet
as a result of that planet,
center of mass has to stay
exactly in the same place. Uh,
and the consequence of this is that
the motion of one clinic is actually a
little bit affected by the
gravity of the other planet.
So it too is executing extra
little wiggles due to, uh,
due to the presence of a second planet.
Those wiggles are very small compared
to the motion that's induced by the sun
because the other planets,
much less massive. Uh, but
they, they really are there.
And in fact,
the planet Neptune was discovered
because the orbit of Uranus,
uh, had extra wiggles in it that couldn't
be accounted for by the known planets.
And so in the,
in the 19th century,
a couple of clever mathematicians figure
it out from the motion of Uranus where
Neptune had to turn out to be a,
in order to explain these extra,
uh,
extra an unexplained motions. And then
some astronomers look in there. It was,
it was a huge triumph for,
uh, a Newtonian physics and a,
and a damned hard math problem
to, uh, and so, uh, uh,
this, this concept becomes a little more
complicated in the case where there are,
uh, uh, more than one planet, but in fact,
the way we're going to deal with that
is just, uh, to separate it into,
into one planet at a time.
Let me give you an example of that.
Uh,
let's see.
I don't think we need to change
the lighting. Whoops. Backwards.
Here we go.
All right.
So this is a radial velocity
curve of some star and it,
uh,
you can see the point here
are the observed radial
velocities and a variety of
times over a course of a
three or four years. And, uh,
then they've drawn in a sine curve or
to actually not quite a sine curve.
It's close to a sine curve and you can
see that the sine curve more or less goes
through these points, which
is nice, uh, because uh,
that indicates the presence of a planet
and you have velocity over here. But, uh,
I should mention something about velocity.
What they'd mean is not actually velocity.
What they mean here is radial velocity.
Uh, and this is an important point.
It's not that the speed changes.
What changes if between here and here
on this plot is not the speed of the
thing, but it's direction. Uh,
because at plus 200 wet meat,
it's going away from you at 200 mile,
uh,
meters per second at minus 200.
It means it's coming towards
you at 200 meters per second.
That's why you can have
a minus velocity at zero.
It does not mean that
the thing has stopped.
It's going at the same speed as it was
up here and the same speed as it goes
down here,
but in a different direction.
So it's going still at 200
plus meters per second,
only it's going sideways.
And so it's neither coming towards
you nor going away from you.
Therefore it's radial velocity is
zero and you measure no doppler shift.
Remember,
these plots are created by measuring
the doppler shift and the doppler shift
tells you how fast something is either
coming towards you or going away from you.
So that's an important point.
Uh,
you can have dramatic changes from
positive to negative in the radio velocity
without changing the speed
of the object at all.
All you have to do is change its
direction. So first it comes towards you,
then it goes sideways, then it goes away
from you Dennett come sideways again.
So that's what this plot represent
a. And you could see that, that,
that these points go up and down
as they should. If something is,
is in orbit around the center of mass,
and these little points down at the
bottom are represent the difference.
Actually they've put it down here.
This should be a zero on the scale.
This is the difference
between the observed points
and this sign your soil model
that they've put up there.
So they've just calculated the
differences and there's some scatter, uh,
but it basically follows a pretty well,
the scattered is a whole lot less
than the, uh, changes in the velocity.
Money.
Turns out you can do better than this.
Here's an example now what
the line is now is not one,
but two sign curves added together,
one of which was the one we saw before.
So they fit for two planets now.
And the other is a another sign curve
with a different amplitude because that
planet induces a smaller,
a motion in the star and
also at different period.
And so at certain points,
uh,
the periods lineup and you
get big deviations, then it,
then at other points you get
wiggles on top of wiggles. Uh,
and these things kind of
beat against each other.
So this complicated pattern of this
line here is just to sign waves added
together and now the points
line up much better. Uh,
if you recall these deviations between
the points in the lines before,
uh, we're, uh, you know, of, uh, uh,
up to say 50 meters a second
and now they're much smaller,
the things fit much better.
I'll show you a blow up now of
this region of the plot, uh,
where a lot of these points are and you'll
see what I mean. Here are the point.
Here is the line and you can see that
this complicated line a really fits these
points quite well. That's evidence that
there are two planets in this system.
Uh, but in fact it gets even better than
that because what they then did was they
said, all right, here's
what we're going to do.
We're going to take these
so called residuals.
We're going to subtract off our two planet
model and we're going to see whether
we can see anything interesting going
on in what's left over after those two
planets have been taken away. And
when they did that, they saw this, uh,
this is, uh, they sort of
grouped them all together. Uh,
and they've found something with
a period of 1.9 days that now has,
uh,
what looks like a sinusoidal wiggle
and have about a few meters per second.
Uh, remember where we started. Uh, the
deviations were 200 meters a second,
but you're now subtract off this, uh, uh,
these two planets and you're
left with a third. And so this,
this system is now known.
This particular star that they were
observing us now known to have three
different planets around it,
of which this one is the one
that has the shortest orbit,
1.9 1.9 days.
So there are now several examples of
things in which we know that there's
actually more than one planet
and one of these systems.
And this is how we find that out.
That the motion of the star is
not just one s one sine curve,
but the superposition of two, or in
this case, even three of these things.
Now, one of the interesting things
about this is it's quite a short orbit.
1.9 days.
That's one of the shortest orbits known.
It also has a relatively low amplitude.
The velocity,
the radial velocity, uh,
changes are quite small.
So the induced speed in
the star is quite small.
Those two things put together,
give you a relatively low mass
of the planet for reasons I'll,
I'll make specific in just a second.
This is one of the lowest mass planets
that's been discovered in this way.
It's only about 10 times the Earth's mass.
Uh,
that's kind of comparable to a little,
a little less than Neptune and
Uranus. Uh, and so in this case,
it isn't actually clear whether you
should think about this thing as a kind of
low mass outer planet or
a big earth like rock.
And so that isn't clear in
this particular place. A case,
let me make this a little
more specific here.
What are the inputs that you need
to know to figure out how big,
how, what the amplitude of that sine
curve is? How big the wiggles are?
You need to know a couple of things.
You need to know the
velocity of the planet,
which isn't what you observe. Remember,
you're observing the velocity of the star,
so the velocity of the planet,
which is approximately equal to
the total velocity. And, uhW,
as one of the exercises,
uh, on your problem set, uh,
you can demonstrate that that is equal
to g m over a the square root of GM over
egg.
So that means,
Yup. Oh yes. Good. Thank
you. How about that?
Yeah.
Uh, okay. So this means Short Orbitz,
uh, give you small, a large
philosophies of the planet.
This makes sense.
If you're in close to the star,
you have to move faster
to keep yourself in orbit.
But of course,
you don't observe the velocity the planet.
You've observed the velocity
of the star velocity.
This star is equal to the
velocity of the planet times, uh,
the mass of the planet over
the mass of the star. And so,
uh,
yeah,
large
planet masses
generate a large star velocities.
So the two things you need to know is,
uh,
how short is the orbit and
how massive is the planet.
And so if you have a short orbit,
uh,
that'll give you high v planet.
And if you observe, so you observe
the short orbit. And the other thing,
if the other thing you observe is a low,
relatively speaking fee star,
then it must be true
that you have a low planet mass
because, uh, if this is
big and this is small,
you've got to compensate for it
by having a small value out here.
And we'll come back to this, uh,
kind of reasoning in a minute.
Does that make sense?
So in fact,
that particular planet with
it's very short orbital period,
but it's low velocity induced
velocity, uh, in the star.
So, so short periods, Short,
semi major access, uh,
but also small v Starr, uh,
is the lowest mass planet,
I think at this point, uh, that has
been observed by this particular method.
Okay.
But as it turns out, most of the
ones, the short or the short period,
planets that have been
observed, uh, are, uh,
are more massive than that. Uh,
and we had got these hot Jupiters.
And so the argument here using this
same kind of reasoning is that you have
short period,
a moderate values,
moderate to high values as
these things go for a v Star.
And that tells you it's a massive
planet. And as I pointed
out last time, uh,
this is deeply disturbing,
uh,
in terms of what we know or what
we think we know about planetary,
uh, about planetary
formation. So a short period,
yeah.
Uh, plus massive is, uh,
to put it mildly unexpected,
so unexpected that they almost
weren't discovered at all. Uh,
what happened is this,
the discovery of 50 the planet
around 51 Pegasus happened in 1995.
And the way this worked out was, uh,
that was a team of astronomers, a Geoff,
Marcy and Paul Butler,
chief among them in California who had
the best equipment for doing these kinds
of, of very high precision
radial velocity measurements.
And they had embarked on a campaign
to find Jupiter like planets,
which they thought they could do.
And they were piling update on many stars.
They were looking at many sunlight
stars. And then one day, uh, in 1995,
they woke up and,
uh,
a bunch of people in Switzerland announced
the discovery of the first planet, uh,
which disturbed the mightily
because they had been scooped.
And it disturbed them even more when
they discovered that the particular star
that this planet was around
this 51 Pegasus thing that
I was talking about last
time was one of the stars that they
themselves had been observing. Uh,
but the thing was the period
you remember was four days.
And when Marcy and Butler and Co,
we're expecting the periods
to turn out to be 10 years.
So they hadn't checked to see whether
there were four day variations.
And as soon as this paper by
these other other astronomers,
these Swiss astronomers who discovered
the thing was published, they said, damn,
we've got a big pile of data on
this particular object in our desk.
We ought to take a look and see
whether these got other guys are ripe.
So they looked at it and you know, within
a week of a re analyzing their data,
they were able to confirm the fact,
uh,
that this really was a planet
in a four day or pit. Uh,
and annoyingly to them,
they already had the data that they
could have announced it first if they'd
looked at it and ask the question,
does this thing actually
have a four day orbit? Uh,
but it didn't occur to them
because it's well known.
You can't have a Jupiter in
a four day orbit. Uh, so they
kind of didn't check. Uh,
so here's another fable for you. Uh, uh,
the discovery, uh, of 51,
peg B, that's how you
label these planets. Uh,
a is the Star B is the
planet. Uh, and the moral, uh,
I guess you could say this in a
couple of ways. One would be to say,
expect the unexpected.
Uh,
and the other would just be to say,
look at your data,
but look at your data,
uh,
so that you could see things that aren't
the thing that you expect to see in
your data. And that's kind
of an important, uh, an
important lesson, I think.
Uh, anyway, uh,
it turned out it was relatively
easy to find these hot Jupiters. Uh,
and within a few years they,
uh,
Marcy and Butler and the Soy sun and
some other teams as well had found
literally dozens of these things.
So within a few years,
uh,
there were dozens of hot Jupiters known
around many stars.
And so
they hadn't yet of course filed anything
like our own solar system because they
hadn't been looking for 10 years yet.
The orbit of Jupiter you will remember,
is 10 years long. Uh, so they found
all these hot Jupiters and uh,
this might have suggested that
ordinary solar systems are rare.
Solar systems,
like our own
planetary systems
are rare.
But I'll put a question mark after that
because it isn't really at all clear
that that's true.
Uh,
and the reason is that hot Jupiters
are easier to find than ordinary solar
systems
for exactly the reasons that I wrote
down just just a minute ago. Uh,
and the fact that they have short periods
and massive planets
generate larger values of the star,
both of those factors make for large
values of the thing that you're actually
trying to observe,
which is the velocity of the star.
So of course if you go out and you have
some new technology and you're trying to
observe something,
the first ones you'll observe are the
ones that have the largest signal that,
uh, uh, of the kind
you're trying to observe.
So if you're observing radial velocities,
you're trying to measure v Star,
the first ones that are going to pop out
at you or the ones with large values of
that. It's also true, uh,
that it's easier to observe
these shorter periods.
If you've got a four day period and
you observe the thing for a month,
you've watched it go back and forth,
uh, you know, eight times or something.
If you want to wait for eight orbital
periods of Jupiter, that 80 years,
uh,
and it's just going to take you longer.
There's a general rule in science that
no project can take longer than it takes
one graduate student to get a Phd.
Uh,
because of course there's the graduate
students who do all the work and it's
just hard to recruit a graduate student
to work on a project that won't be
completed until they're
70. Uh, and um, uh,
so the, these shorter periods
are easier to observe, uh,
just because they're short.
In addition to the fact that the thing
you were observing a is much easier to
see.
This is called a selection effect.
So you're just more likely to see certain
kinds of objects than others for the
or for the straightforward reasons
that they're easier to see. Uh,
and those will be the ones you find first.
And if you don't take this into account
and thinking about the statistics of
these things,
you're going to screw up.
Because of course you see the
easy ones first. Of course,
you see lots of them before you see
the others. Uh, nevertheless, uh,
the existence of even one hot Jupiter,
uh,
was a crisis for planetary formation
theories because there's no way any such
thing ought to exist. So, but, uh,
even one hot Jupiter,
uh, messes up our theory. So
I'll just write that down.
NASA's up theory
aunt.
So as soon as even the first of
these was, uh, was discovered, uh,
people, uh, started to think about
what the alternatives might be.
Uh,
and there are two kinds of alternatives
that think ways to explain the data
without having a hot Jupiter.
So alternative number one,
uh, was that, uh,
a cell called low inclination double star.
So I'll explain that in a second.
The second object,
and this is supposed to be a star,
not a planet,
and there are known a double
stars with short periods.
They're formed in a very different way.
Double Stars don't form the second star
doesn't necessarily form out of a disc
around the first storage form.
I Dunno by splitting the star in half
at some early part of it, uh, uh,
of its evolution until you get a very
different expectation for what kinds of
periods you have in there.
Many stars,
double stars known with short
periods of this kind. But, uh,
so then how do you explain,
uh, if it was a double star,
you would expect that the
induced velocity would be much,
much bigger because the
is much more massive.
And so what you do is you explain it
by saying, well, here is your, uh, uh,
here as you were observing it and the
orbit of the orbital plane is like this.
It goes up and down. So the stars
are orbiting each other this way.
So they neither come towards you
very much, nor go away from you. Uh,
and, uh, therefore the, uh, radio,
the velocity is high,
but the radio velocity,
which is the thing you observe is low.
So,
so
high velocity,
but low radio velocity,
uh,
because the system was
going sideways or buts are,
uh,
the technical term here is face on,
not edge on.
Okay.
Uh,
so that was one hypothesis. Uh, this
didn't work out for two reasons.
Problem number one,
no evidence
for light from more than one star.
Okay?
Stars are much brighter
than planets, right? So, uh,
if you're looking at a star planet system,
all you expect to see is the light from
one star. And that's what is observed.
If you've got a second star
in that system, the second
star shines like a star.
And so you would expect to
see some evidence of light
from a second star in that
system. And, and none of
those was observed. Uh,
the other problem is a kind
of statistical one. Uh,
there are many hot Jupiters.
Now,
if you're going to explain
all these things by, uh,
having face on orbits with respect to us,
imagine what some observer somewhere
else in the galaxy with all these things.
Here's us in the middle of, of, of
our galaxy or somewhere in our galaxy.
And all of these objects happened to
be lined up exactly face on toward us.
Uh, some other astronomer
somewhere else, uh,
would have to see them edge
on and so forth. So why is it,
what cosmic conspiracy has caused
all these things to be lined up, uh,
uh, face on toward us. It's as if
someone had carefully set up all these,
uh, all these double star systems to
fool us into thinking that hot Jupiters
existed. Uh, this is the
kind of argument, uh,
that people tend to reject because it
requires that we are in a very special
place or that some very special
coincidence has taken place. Uh,
and that isn't, uh, and as you keep
finding more and more of these things,
you wonder, well, how come
aren't some of them lined up,
uh, uh, edge on and in fact,
it has to be very close to face on.
And so the odds that all
of these things have, uh,
our face on to within plus
or minus one degree, uh,
starts to become really small. Uh, as you
pile up more and more of these objects,
many hot Jupiters,
they can't all be face on.
And so as more and more of
these things were discovered,
you could explain any one or perhaps
two of them is being faced on stars,
a star systems. But, uh,
it starts to get more and more difficult
to believe that all of them are in that
category. Okay. Uh,
let me see. What do I want to do
here? Okay. Alternative number two.
Okay.
Uh,
is pulsating stars.
Now this is interesting.
Some pop stars do pulsate the
Sun pulsates just a little bit,
not enough so that you
could see it in this way.
But there are other stars known that
pulsate by large amounts, they go out,
they go in. Think about what happens
if you observe a pulsating star.
Here it is when it's small,
but getting bigger. Uh,
so all of the star is expanding,
but if you look at that star,
you only see the half of the star
that's on your side of the star.
So you only see this part over here
and all of the surface of that star is
coming towards you, right?
Cause this part, it's expanding.
So this part's coming towards you.
This part's going half sideways,
half towards you. This part's
going half side. You and have, uh,
have sideways half towards you. So if
you add up the light from all of this,
it has a net bulk motion
coming towards you. Now,
supposing you look at it when it's at a
different part of it's a pulsation cycle.
So now it's big, but
going, uh, but falling in
now you'll see the opposite.
All of the parts of this star
are moving away from you.
Some are moving sort of sideways, but
others are moving away from you. Uh,
and so you expect that if
you observe a pulsating star,
you'll see first positive radio velocity,
van,
negative radio velocity.
Then as it pulses back out again,
positive radial velocity.
And that starts to sound very familiar,
right? That's pretty much what we observe.
It goes up, it goes down. Uh,
and so the suggestion was that,
uh, uh, these things might actually be
some kind of pulsating star. Uh, okay.
So problems with the
pulsating star explanation.
Uh, basically, uh, solar
type stars, which these were,
stars are suppose to pulsate like this,
to have art supposed to
have large pulsations.
Uh, and, uh, it's also
true that pulsations
in general don't lead to
sinusoidal variations in radio.
Velocity in orbit naturally
gives rise to a sine wave.
If the orbits close to
circular, uh, pulsations,
there's no particular
reason to have that pattern.
You could have sudden rises and then
gradual decays and then things of that
nature. You don't expect it to be signed
your soil. Uh, but both of these things,
you know,
what's weird is that there are a lot of
hot Jupiters in the world or that you
have some kind of pulsation mechanism,
but you haven't experienced before.
Both of them are sort of equally,
uh,
in violation of current
theory. And so, uh,
you might as well assume that you have
weird pulsations as well as having weird
planets. Uh, however,
it turns out that the pulsation
theory makes a testable prediction.
And to explain this prediction,
I have to take a little digression and
talk a little bit about how doppler
shifts are actually measured.
Uh,
so measuring
doppler shifts,
uh,
what you do is you look at,
uh, what's called a spectrum.
Those of you who, uh, Spec, no,
Gosh, I've spelled that wrong.
Uh,
spectrum
spectrum is just a plot of intensity,
how much light there is
a against wavelength.
And if you a workout,
if you met her,
the spectrum of any particular
astronomical object, uh, you'll see,
uh,
that at certain wave lengths there is
much less intensity or much more intensity
than at many other wavelengths.
So you'll get a plot that
looks kind of like this.
There'll be specific wave lanes that
have abnormally large or abnormally small
amounts of light coming from them.
Uh,
these are referred to as spectral
features or sometimes lines. Uh,
and when you have too little,
these are called absorption lines.
These are called emission lines because
you have extra emission or absorption of
radiation at those particular wavelengths.
Uh,
there's a good explanation of why
this happens from atomic physics.
I won't go into detail, uh,
but let me just say that. Uh,
so there are specific wave lengths
with,
uh,
much less or much more emission
or more mission.
And each one of those wavelengths
is caused by a atomic transitions,
which emit more or absorb a
particular wavelengths of life light.
So caused by a atomic,
uh,
transitions.
I won't explain what those are in,
in detail, uh, but,
but each comes from a specific,
uh, chemical element. So hydrogen has pit,
particular hydrogen has particular
wavelengths associated with it.
Helium has particular wavelengths
associated with it, uh,
and so on and so on and
so forth. Uh, and uh, you,
and this by the way,
is how you can determine what,
what stars are made out of
determine a composition of stars.
But for the present purpose,
the point is that you can go in with a
bunch of hydrogen in the laboratory and
measure what the wavelengths
of the spectral features are.
If nothing is moving, uh, so can measure
these
wavelengths at rest in a lab.
And so, you know, when you advance what
the rest wavelengths of these things are,
you go out and measure them in stars
and it turns out they're not quite where
they're supposed to be. And that's
how you determine what the, uh,
what the doppler shift of any particular
object is by comparing these spectral
features to where they are in the lab.
Uh,
now here's a, so, uh, if we
go back to talking about, uh,
pulsations.
So here is,
this is kind of a blow up
of
and absorption line in this case.
Yeah.
So here's the intensity
and here's wavelength.
And it looked something like this are,
so there's particular set
of wavelengths that are, uh,
uh, that are absorbed. Now,
if the whole star moves,
if the star is moving because
there's a planet around it, uh,
what happens when it gets red shifted?
Well,
this whole thing moves to the right to
longer wavelengths and you get something
that looks, you know, sorta like,
yes.
So this is a whole star moves away from
you until the whole thing shifts back
and forth.
But pulsations are a little bit different
when the,
when you get a red shift due to pulsation,
it's because you know,
you're looking at something that does
this part of the star moves away from you,
but part of the star move sideways.
Yeah.
And so only part of, uh,
the mission is red shifted,
but other parts of the emission are not.
Uh,
and so what you do is,
uh, uh, you sort of,
it's not like the whole
thing moves sideways.
It's that it sorta gets smushed
out because part of the SA, uh,
part of the star moves sideways, but
as part of the part of the re, uh,
absorbed from line moves sideways,
but part of the absorption line doesn't
move because it's coming. You know,
it's like coming from this part of the
star, which is going sideways to you.
And so what you do is you get
something that looks more like this.
So this is part of the star moves away.
So the center of a of this line has moved.
Here's the center here.
It's gotten even, uh,
even more red shifted then in the case
I drew there. Uh, but part of it has,
has been left behind.
And so the prediction,
okay,
is that for, uh, pulsations,
the shape of the,
uh,
of these spectral features changes,
shape of lines
change,
whereas for orbital motion,
only the position
of the lines change.
So this can be observed.
You can go out and observe and you can
see whether the shape of the lunch change
or not. And they did that,
uh, and it not pulsation,
uh,
but is consistent with orbits.
I think this is kind of a cool
experiment because you know,
this looks a lot like science,
right? There's two hypotheses,
each of which makes a different
prediction. Prediction
what hypothesis? One,
it's got to change its shape hypothesis
too. It does not change its shape.
You go out, you measure the thing and
you find out which hypothesis is right.
This is just what they told you
in eighth grade. And therefore,
just what I told you a couple of days
ago never happens in astronomy. Uh,
but sometimes it does. Uh, and
so this is yet another fable,
uh, the disproof, uh,
of pulsation as explanation
for the velocity curves.
And the moral here is sometimes
science works like science.
So there were for several years,
all of these attempts to try
and explain he hot Jupiter,
the radio velocity curves without actually
having to bite the bullet and believe
that hot Jupiters exist. None of them
were very convincing. Uh, this, uh,
double star hypothesis
didn't seem to work out.
The pulsation hypothesis didn't seem
to work out, but nevertheless, people,
uh,
kept trying to come up with alternative
explanations until something happened.
Uh, they're pretty much
nailed down. Uh, the, uh,
the idea that these things really
honest to goodness are, uh, planets. Uh,
but I don't have time to
tell you about that now,
so we'll talk about it on Thursday.
Okay.